I like my name is Samuel Leeds and on
this video I'm gonna give you just two
there's dozens but I want to give you
two ways how anybody can be a rich
property entrepreneur so stay tuned okay
[Music]
number one and you can do this
regardless if you have no money
regardless if you have no experience at
the moment in property whatever your
situation wherever you're from whatever
your color anybody can find a property
deal go and view lots of properties with
the state agents or find properties on
gumtree or wherever go and view
properties and put offers on find a
property negotiate the offer below the
asking price get it at a good price even
kids kids can negotiate kids can get a
deal get a deal and then when you have
the deal pass it on to somebody and
charge a fee now typically the fee that
you might get could be two three four
thousand pounds one of those a month and
you have replaced an average salary you
are now a professional full time
property entrepreneur and why can't you
do that you can't anyone can do that
so that's number one second one is to
find properties that are up for rent and
find a way to increase the rent you
could cut it up and turn it into a hey
cello just by putting fire doors and
smoke alarms in the property rent it off
the landlord and this is not so blessing
if it's done illegally it's called rent
to rent rent it off the landlord and
then put tenants in and any profit that
you make you keep you're not owning the
property you're controlling the property
most successful companies at the moment
very big companies Amazon uber uber
don't own any cars but you think of them
was the biggest taxi company in the
world Airbnb that I own any properties
but they are one of the biggest hotel
industries in the world on the planet so
you can make serious money as a property
entrepreneur with strategies like rent
around where you control the property
you don't own it starting from scratch
making income as a property on summer
starting with nothing I mean you know
what guys it's just about being creative
it's just about taking action and
implementation if you're inspired share
this video if you have any questions
challenges problems posted below I'll do
my best to answer god bless see you next
time thank you so much for watching if
you benefited from that
please do share it with your family and
friends for more videos like it you can
watch right here and if you'd like to
spend two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time